thank you  yeah is the staff of which fairy tales  are made  the prince and princess on their wedding  day  [Applause]  [Music]  but fairy tales usually end at this  point with the simple phrase they lived  happily ever after  [Music]  [Applause]  thank you  foreign  [Applause]  but the place where the adventure really  begins  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  the escort under the command of  Lieutenant Colonel Andrew Parker Bowles  lose Royals as Charles Lady Diana stayed  with him and his wife Camilla and  Wiltshire on two occasions at the end of  the year so that among friends as they  ride along the map  [Applause]  foreign  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  foreign  foreign  what made it so special for you Hetty  well I just see all them people  yes you weren't actually amongst them  then no no I was at home watching very  sensible I should think it was pretty  crowded out there wasn't it it was but  it's a fantastic marvelous proud to be  British my dear